et xavier moreau expert en relations
internationales et fondateur de strates
paul est avec nous sur ce plateau
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors c'est une annonce
qui a surpris tout le monde comment est
ce que vous comprenez cette démission
juste après le discours de vladimir
poutine
on le disait il ya quelques instants je
crois que l'avenir poutine veut placer
son dernier mandat sous le signe des
réformes et surtout signe du social
comme on a pu le voir et que donc il a
voulu nommer quelqu'un qui dont la
question d'homme à poigne et qui est
connu comme étant un homme à poigne
un technicien est quelqu'un d'orienter
beaucoup vers la la numérisation à
l'économie numérique
donc pour continuer on va dire c'est les
réformes qui ont été tout de même
commencé déjà depuis plusieurs années
donc là vous nous parlez de michail
michaud estime que assez peu
connaissaient avant oui oui honnêtement
c'est une don qu'il dirige est
effectivement le fisc le fisc russe les
des impôts
et encore une fois c'est comme ça qu'il
est connu c'est à dire comme étant un
homme avec un management très très
efficace qui va au fond des choses qui
vérifie énormément ce qui pouvait en
effet quelques fois reproché à dimitri
medvedev
ces deux pas dans un pays vous imaginez
qui s'étend sur 25 fuseau horaire comme
la russie et bien lorsque vous faites
des réformes que vous donnez des ordres
il faut vérifier qu'elle soit appliquée
jusqu'au 20 fond de la sibérie ce qui ce
qui n'a pas été toujours le cas ce qui
fait que alors que la russie est un pays
riche par exemple où il ya des budgets
qui sont distribués dans les régions
quelquefois il n'était même pas utiliser
ou quelquefois il y avait plus d'argent
mais les autorités locales
n'osaient pas en demander donc il faut
quelqu'un qui soit peut-être plus dur
dans l'exécution de décision du
gouvernement russe
est ce qu'on peut parler d'un tournant
dans le système politique russe
aujourd'hui j'ai plutôt l'impression que
c'est une évolution logique
je pense qu'il ya eu différentes phases
dans l'histoire récente de la russie
depuis l'arrivée de l'ère poutine
la première période ça a été de remettre
en place les institutions d'appliquer la
constitution dans toutes les banques de
l'est sujet de la fédération de russie
la deuxième étape qui était à peu près
parallèle c'était le redressement de
l'économie russe et aujourd'hui on est
finalement dans et bien le l'ultime
étape qui est la modernisation de la
russie
économiquement et là la redistribution
de la richesse dans l'ensemble des
régions russes pour pousser jusqu'au
bout et bien ces réformes qui sont qui
sont nécessaires quand le président
vladimir poutine juge le pays mûrs pour
cela c'est donc cela dont il parle c'est
à dire que la russie est aujourd'hui mur
pour cette modernisation
la russie est mûr de point de vue je
dirais du point de vue politique les
russes ont montré qu'ils avaient atteint
une maturité politique
tout à fait tout à fait convenable et du
point de vue économique aussi parce
qu'en fait si vous écoutez les annonces
qui ont été faites il va y avoir
beaucoup d'argent qui va être distribué
alors la russie est un pays riche donc
elle a les moyens de le faire mais la
politique familiale un autant la voilà
donc il ya par exemple dire plus de 6000
euros pour le premier enfant mais en en
parité de pouvoir d'achat c'est comme si
vous donniez au premier enfant en france
quinze mille euros voyez et au deuxième
enfant
six cent vingt mille roubles de mémoire
ça fait vingt mille euros
donc c'est beaucoup d'argent qui vont
être distribués c'est aussi je pense à
un signe du dirait du poutinisme c'est à
dire que eh bien on investit dans un
avenir qui ne concernera même plus
vadimir poutine puisque évidemment
toutes les décisions démographique
produiront leurs effets alors on espère
on espère dès l'année prochaine mais
globalement c'est pas pour la demo
poutine qu il le fait il a vraiment une
haute idée de sa de la fonction
présidentielle et la démographie et pour
la russie comme pour les tous les pays
européens
le sujet peut-être le sujet le plus
important et le plus grave est ce qu'on
va plus vers plus de libéralisme en
russie avec ces annonces alors je
lançais dépend sur quel niveau vous
placez le libéral ici c'est libéralisme
économique la russie est un pays libéral
vous comparer le fonctionnement c'est
plutôt la france qui est un pays nef
socialiste sur le modèle soviétique
plutôt que doc la russie donc point de
vue économique la russie et a déjà un
pays libéral il ya plus de
redistribution c'est clair jusqu'il ya
un vénissian qui viennent qui viennent
d'être prises il ya toujours une volonté
de ne pas tomber dans la maladie
hollandaise c'est à dire de vouloir
vivre des revenus du pétrole à je vous
rappelle que dès que le baril dépasse 40
dollars tout ce qui est au dessus et
mises dans le fonds de réserve
donc on ne veut pas on veut que
l'économie soit de plus en plus
dépendante des hydrocarbures
ça c'est une chose est maintenant est ce
qu'on aura plus de libéralisme je pense
que vous faisiez allusion
du point de vue politique de ce que je
vois à moscou y compris les débats sur
les chaînes de télé je pense que la
russie n'a pas grand chose à envier
aux autres démocraties occidentales donc
qu'elle suive son choix après on va voir
ce que va devenir la russie après
vladimir poutine
peut-être que edinaïa rossiya le parti
du kremlin va disparaître et parce que
finalement il ya à l'intérieur de russie
unie à des débats il ya des néo étatiste
il ya des libéraux comme vous dites il
ya des socios conservateur donc il ya le
gros qui est le plus gros courant qui
semble aujourd'hui triompher si on en
voit si on en juge les décisions qui
sont prises va nuire par vladimir
poutine
quelles sont quelques heures après cette
annonce surprise bel et bien les les
interrogations les questionnements pour
ce qui va arriver dans les heures les
jours qui vont venir
disons qu'elle alors la nomination donc
du nouveau premier ministre est plutôt
bien prise j'écoutais les médias russes
en venant
tout le monde répète ce que ce que je
vous ai dit au début de l'interview
c'est à dire que c'est un un technocrate
mais on va dire au bon sens du terme
c'est quelqu'un qui fait qui sait ce qui
fait je pense qu'on n'aura pas dans le
nouveau de gros changements au sein du
nouveau gouvernement puisque
traditionnellement le gouvernement russe
est un ce sont des gouvernements de
spécialistes vous avez le mix de
l'énergie est un spécialiste de
l'énergie le ministre de la défense est
un général et c'est donc qu'on a on va
voir un gouvernement technocratique donc
c'est plutôt rassurant et dans
l'ensemble la nomination du nouveau
premier ministre est plutôt bien prise
d'ailleurs vous le voyez sur les marchés
ou sur le cours du rouble
il est extrêmement stable il ya eu bon
quelques oscillations ce qu'est ce qui
est ce qui est normal mais globalement
la russie régis réagi de tous les points
de vue du maire plutôt sereine merci
beaucoup vous aviez un morrow d'avoir
partager votre avis sur notre plateau je
rappelle que vous êtes expert en
relations internationales et fondateur
de strates paul